casa por cárcel de facto y una
investigación penal en su contra así
castigo el gobierno del presidente
nicaragüense daniel ortega al obispo de
matagalpa rolando álvarez a quien acusa
de intentar organizar grupos violentos
con el propósito de desestabilizar al
estado de nicaragua y atacar a las
instituciones constitucionales
la policía nacional como autoridad
competente para garantizar la paz y la
seguridad ciudadana ha establecido
medidas de protección a la población
para que estos hechos no se vuelvan a
repetir asimismo ha iniciado un proceso
de investigación con finalidad de
determinar la responsabilidad penal de
las personas involucradas en comisión de
estos actos delictivos de los cuales se
ha informado al ministerio público y al
poder judicial las personas investigadas
se mantendrán en sus casas
el anuncio de la policía se produce
horas después de que la vicepresidenta y
vocera gubernamental rosario murillo
amenazar a los sacerdotes y llamar a
bufonería al llamado de paz y de diálogo
del obispo y un día después de que la
policía acercara a la casa episcopal de
matagalpa donde se encontraban además
del monseñor seis sacerdotes y seis
laicos esto luego de que el religioso
criticar el cierre de varios medios
católicos la mayoría liderados por su
diócesis una medida que continúa y que
ha sido mal recibida por los ciudadanos
estos problemas que no le podemos hacer
problemas sino que son situaciones de
pruebas que estamos pasando los los
católicos en estos momentos ya que la
iglesia está siendo perseguida
solamente por predicar el evangelio
solamente por eso porque lo único que
hacemos ahora alabar al señor
glorificarlo la iglesia emitió un
comunicado de respaldo hacia el
religioso pero varias organizaciones
opositoras reclaman el silencio del
vaticano que hasta ahora no se pronuncia
sobre la situación en nicaragua